I was wondering what would break first
I've been planning and researching this
post for a while if you want to train
like Batman or even just like an athlete
then preventing injury and optimizing
recovery is crucial the harder you push
yourself in workouts and the more varied
your training the more critical it is
that you balance that out with optimal
recovery and healing strategies knowing
this I've been employing multiple
strategies for many years to try and
ensure I do both but then a week ago I
put my back out and no it wasn't because
Bane broke me over one knee it was
significantly less awesome than that I
bent over an awkward angle while picking
up my 15 month daughter on a walk and it
caused a muscle strain in my lower back
then I came down with a mega cold which
is why my voice sounds a little bit
funny and no I don't think it's that
mega cold I thought for a while about
not writing this post after all I felt
like a bit of a hypocrite but then I
realized a few things firstly everyone
gets injured from time to time
there's simply no strategy that can
promise you will never get hurt or never
get ill and I wouldn't want to claim
otherwise also this was the perfect time
for me to assess what went wrong how it
could be prevented in future and how I
was going to accelerate my healing and
get back to training I'm learning along
with you guys it's all part of the
journey so I did even more research and
now I'm ready to suggest how Batman
might optimize his healing and prevent
injuries on the job and what all we mere
mortals could learn from that
[Music]
one of the ways I've always tried friend
injury and one of the tools Batman
should certainly employ is to strengthen
the tendons these are what connect our
muscles to our bones allowing us to
exert force through our joints
unfortunately they also adapt to
strength training in even anabolic
hormones much more slowly than muscle
does this is one reason that steljis can
actually lead to more injuries as the
muscles grow much faster than the
tendons can keep up whereas new lifters
can see structural changes within the
muscle in as little as eight days it
takes up to two months for similar
change to occur in tendons that makes it
important that you spend at least two
months building up a basic level of
strength before you start pushing
yourself with a serious progressive
overload it's also why Batman might
choose to use high volume calisthenics
as a method to increase blood supply to
both muscle and the tendons the issue is
that connective tissue doesn't have as
much blood supply as muscle during 300
press up several times a week for a few
weeks we'll actually increase the number
of capillaries supplying those muscles
and tendons with blood this can also aid
hypertrophy meaningly responds better to
training the future high volume
calisthenics also has the added bonus of
improving work capacity thereby
improving efficiency over time to
prevent sloppy form being introduced as
training goes on I recommend sticking
with simpler low stress exercises like
push-ups and pull-ups you can also vary
the specific movements you use between
workouts in order to minimize the amount
of repetition on the joints another
method I use is training for everything
I can by that I mean not just training
in a single plane of movement but
working on things like rotational
strength and mobility Batman should
certainly do the same by training with
calisthenics animal movements sandbags
kettlebells and more this is important
as some more rigid approaches to
training can otherwise actually compound
the issues the modern life already
introduces when you sit at a computer
all day hunched over you create
tightness and certain muscles like the
pecs and the hamstrings while
lengthening and weakening others the
same thing happens if you show
preferential treatment to certain body
parts if you only train the big three
lifts or worse the mirror muscles then
you'll build back some strength in areas
like the hamstrings but completely
ignore external rotation of the
shoulders rotational strength etc
rotational strength is not sexy but it's
crucial for every single sport and
certainly in combat whether you're
grappling or twisting your body to throw
a punch
this is the type of strength you need
likewise it's the strength you need when
moving furniture or when you turn to
pass something to someone behind you as
Pat McKenna Mara told Joe Rogan's in the
transverse plane lives life saving and
ass-kicking if you have let your
obliques become weak then sudden
movements in this position could result
in a tear or an injury and if you only
ever train the attractive muscles on the
front of your body and the work a desk
job then a shoulder injury is just
waiting to happen if you spend your days
with a whole lot of tension pulling your
body forwards all the time it has been
said that gymnasts are particularly
resilient against injury considering the
huge amount of high-impact training they
do I don't know how true that is as I've
also heard specific gymnasts a that they
find it unusual not to be in pain but
the point stands that they do incredible
things without breaking their backs
how by training in ways that many
conventional strength training methods
overlooked or even actively avoid Chris
summers of gymnastic bodies recommends
using the Jefferson curl to strengthen
the back for example this involves
actively rounding the spine under load
which can feel extremely unnatural to
those of us who have always been taught
to keep our backs neutral during most
lifts but the point is that your back
has mobility there it's designed to do
that you can avoid moving that way in
the gym but not in real life so why not
strengthen it the key is simply to know
what you're doing and I highly recommend
practicing with a coach and to start
with very light weights you can also
take a look at old-time strongmen for
demonstrations of this they would do
seemingly insane things like bending
backwards while pressing weights this
kind of thing might look bonkers but the
point is that by training at these
awkward angles they become stronger in
them they become ready for anything but
and this is a big one you absolutely
should not do anything that looks crazy
or dangerous without the help of a coach
and using very light weights to start
with while your body may be capable of
doing that it's not currently optimized
for it but if I knew all this then what
went wrong if I'm used to doing single
arm kettlebell clean and presses with my
thirty-six kilogram kettlebell why did
picking up my 13 kilogram daughter with
both hands take me down there are
several answers to that question one of
these is the specifics of the movement
I've developed twisting movements and
I've developed squatting movements but
in this case I was walking in one
direction twisting backwards to catch my
daughter who wanted to go the other way
all while bending down on an even
terrain I was spending over rather than
squatting because I didn't have much
time to react and that route is covered
in potholes that meant my backwards also
rounded I might have done the occasional
Jefferson curl and I might have trained
my rotational strength but both at the
same time with a very unusual angle of
resistance moving away from me first
thing in the morning when the cold wall
run down you get the picture
one option would be to focus on
combining movements and on transitioning
between movements a squat a deadlift or
a bicep curl are all examples of
constrained movements those are
one-dimensional repetitive movement
patterns in real life we rarely use
constraining from patterns but rather
these dynamically adapts to
ever-changing demands so one has to
solve this disparity is to use movement
training training systems like animal
flow are all about linking movements
together and transitioning through all
planes of motion they also include the
large amounts of spinal articulation and
rotation and no two workouts are ever
the same of course you don't have to
follow a predefined training program
like animal flow in order to get used to
using animal movements in your own
workouts trail running using barefoot
shoes can similarly prepare us for
uneven terrain and ground more of nuts
is built around this kind of philosophy
another option is to use more hybrid
exercises that combine two or more
movements into a single repetition and
discuss this in my most recent Batman
training program all we can go one step
further with another interesting
training protocol called loaded movement
training first described in this form by
Michael Dowell quartz Viper system VIP
are this type of training revolves
around task oriented movement patterns
under load this kind of training
challenges the body in a variety of
different ways and can help build that
legendary farmer strength that gives a
manual workers seemingly invincible
tendons and a bulletproof mentality it's
fantastic for building up tendon
strength and building more resilience
especially in your core
another factor is mobility this is an
issue I know I had I've been performing
pistol squats on the daily basis but if
you look at my form I actually have
quite a rounded back this is due to a
lack of mobility of my right ankle which
in turn is a hangover from a very old
injury and avulsion fracture caused by
an errant rabbit hole this prevented my
need from moving further forwards which
forced me to round my back to stay
upright now rounded back isn't actually
a serious crime when there's no load but
doing this daily mostly likely cost a
little bit of tension on my back prior
to the movement now we have in
everything that I spoke about before and
have a recipe for disaster this is just
one of the reasons that mobility should
be emphasized if you want to improve
your longevity in training
it's also why assessing your own Foreman
being honest about your own mistakes and
limitations is important to keep in mind
as well that limited mobility can be
acute as well as chronic an injury can
cause tension for example as can stress
this is why I recommend doing a short
diagnostic check before each workout you
can do this during a warm-up or even as
part of a body scan meditation which
also helped to strengthen the mind
muscle connection for further reduced
injury risk in short you check in with
each muscle group to see whether it's
feeling stiff or painful although it's
carrying any tension from there you can
then try to address those issues with
frame rolling or simply decide not to
push too hard in that area during a
given workout ultimately this is the
difference between treating training
light cube job if you can't afford to be
injured then you need to be slow and
deliberate in your training you need to
train for longevity not from your ego
that's when training becomes serious and
Batman is always serious that's it for
part 1 guys stay tuned for part 2 where
I'll be discussing recovery and don't
worry about me and my back I'm already
starting to exercise lightly once again
and I've nearly finished this cold
despite what my voice might sound like
hopefully by the next video I'll be ripe
as rain so thanks ton for watching guys
if you enjoyed this then please share it
around and like comment and subscribe
all those things to help me out
immensely and stay tuned for the next
one bye for now
oh and if you like this kind of approach
to training it incorporates lots of
different methodologies then you'll
probably enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training you
find that in the link in the description
down below
you